كما انه سيتم التعامل بحزم مع كل من يقوم
باعمال نهب او يهاجم مؤسسات الدوله
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم مدن فرنسيه عديده تشهد
تصاعدا في الاحتجاجات لليوم الثالث على
التوالي بعد مقتل الشاب على يد شرطي
خلال اجتماعي لخليه الازمه بالتعامل بحزم
ويعلن ونشر تعزيزات اضافيه للسيطره على
اعمال الشغب رئيسه الوزراء تقول ان جميع
الخيارات مطروحه بما فيها اعلان حاله
الطوارئ لاستعاده الامن
كيف تعبر عن مخاوف من بطء الهجوم المضاد
وتقول انه دون الامداد الغربي الكامل
ستكون الخطط العسكريه غير مجديه على
الاطلاق
وموسكو تتحدث عن ساين غربي لتجميد الصراع
في اوكرانيا
لمنحكيف فرصه للراحه قبل تزويدها مجددا
بالسلاح ا واشنطن تكشف انها تدرس نقل رؤوس
حربيه للداخائر العنقوديه الى اوكرانيا
لجنه المانيه المستقله تخلص في تقرير
اصدرته الى ان ما يعانيه المسلمون من
تمييز المتزايد في المجتمع الالماني يبرر
اتخاذ اجراءات متضافره لمكافحه الكراهيه
والتحيز ضدهم وزيره الداخليه تقول ان
الحكومه ستدرس نتائج التقرير وتوصياته
وستعمل على مكافحه التمييز وحمايه
المسلمين بشكل افضل
مع تقديرات تشير الى اختفاء اكثر من 100
الف شخص منذ بدء الثوره الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده تصادق على قرار انشاء مؤسسه
مستقله معنيه بالمفقودين في سوريا برعايه
الامم المتحده القرار جاء بعد موافقه 83
دوله ومعارضه احدى عشره دوله اخرى الى
اللقاء